[Musique]
l'egypte y sont inquiets ils ne voient
plus sur leur télévision les marins
shadoks tourner en rond dans l'espace
que sont ils devenus
et bien voilà une nuit comme d'habitude
les marins shadoks avait débarqué chez
eux pour s'emparer subrepticement de
leur fusée il avait eu beaucoup de mal
pour la ramener à leur bord car la nuit
était noire et la mer apparemment avait
montée ils avaient été obligés
d'escalader l'eau pour monter dans leur
bateau mais plus ils rament air plus il
restait au même endroit et au matin ils
y étaient encore
il s'était tout simplement trompé de
bateaux car comme vous le savez les
shadoks persuadé que les marins à l'est
vers leurs pertes leurs avait à l'avancé
ériger un monument et il s'était monté
dedans quand les autres shadoks voyant
leurs fusées revenus soit plus mon père
thalasso pour essayer de la récupérer le
bas-rhin shadoks lui griller à
l'abordage à l'abordage l'egypte ils
nous attaquent
car il croyait qu'il avait affaire à des
jbe déguisés et il l'est pour se roder
le conte inspira pendant des jours et
des mots qui périssaient d'autres
étaient plus ou moins définitivement
estropiés mais qui allait gagner
[Musique]